i'm councillor keith wallam and i'm
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt
the meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent
or switched off i would like to remind
everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed
by the council to have consented to
being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully
excluded
can i move to the agenda please
i would like to take item 13 directly
after item 9
both our reports on housing matters so i
think that makes sense
can i also move item 7 that's the key
decisions list
so that we look at the key decisions
list and items 10 and 11
the work plans together i think that's
logical
rather than taking taking them
separately so
if you are all happy with that
can i ask if there are any apologies for
absence and
substitutions please
uh ch check sir this is counselling i'm
substituting for
councillor hadingham thank you
can i now ask the governance officer to
take a roll call
of the members present yes certainly
chair can i just introduce the officers
first who are here please
and we have christine a professional
lead for keysights and infrastructure
we have robert harps a corporate manager
strategic planning
and need benec strategic planning policy
and infrastructure
officer and louise barker for housing
enabling officer and that's all for item
8. and fighter 9 and 13 we have
gavin fisk assistant director for
housing heather tucker corporate manager
for housing solutions
and louise barker housing enabling
officer and i think we might also have
justin king who's from parkside housing
so members um i'll now take your
attendance please um councillor
uh sean dawson
okay counselor jane gould
yes good morning good morning councillor
catherine grandin
good morning councillor uh alastair
mccraw
good morning councillor adrian osborne
good morning president and for paper
council we have received apologies from
councillor mary mclaren
we now move to mid-southwark district
council councilor terence carter
good morning council james caston
and we come to councillor um
paul eckan young who is substituting for
council of india hattingham
good morning councillor dave muller
good morning council keith scarf morning
and counselor willem good morning
thank you
uh can we receive any declarations of
pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest by members are
there any to declare please
yeah yes i have a local non-coiny
interest regarding the
uh df um disabled
housing that's item
13 the disabled facilities grants yeah
thank you
item three confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny
committee held on the 4th of september
these minutes are deferred to the next
meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
can we receive notification of any
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme please
none received thank you
uh questions by the public none received
uh item six questions by councillors
none received chair thank you
item seven we are deferring until we uh
we get to item 10 and 11.
so we're now moving on to item
eight scrutiny and first review of the
baba and mid-suffolk
housing delivery test action plans and
i'd like to invite christine thurlow
professional lead for key sites and
infrastructure
to introduce the report please
good morning everybody the housing
delivery test action plan requirement
was because
uh government introduced a measure in
february 2019 called the housing
delivery
test um the housing delivery test
produced a figure that each council
should hit in terms of housing delivery
so in february 2019 for baber it was 420
and for mid-suffolk it was 5-5-6 and
in the first housing delivery test uh
baber achieved 88 percent
uh of that figure and mid suffolk
achieved 81
of that figure um this meant that both
councils had to produce
um a housing delivery test action plan
by august 2010
so after quite a bit of work
um both councils did indeed produce a
housing delivery test action plan and it
was adopted
by both councils in june and placed on
the website
in order that that deadline was met
and it was our intention at the time and
members signaled this
uh that we should produce one each year
whether it be for legislative purposes
or not on the grounds to do so
would be good practice and uh be due
diligence
um so the housing delivery test action
plan is required to be evidential and it
must be the subject
of um stakeholder uh consultation
and so our evidence for both action
plans is set out in your document
uh in the report at 4.3
uh i won't go all through that no doubt
you you're familiar
with it um following adoption of the
joint housing
um following adoption surrey of the
joint
homes and housing strategy and then the
production
of uh the um hdtap
um there were work streams leads set up
for each of the 23 work streams that we
identified as being the ones that we
should
uh focus on and you have got uh three of
the people that have been actively
engaged on that project
here today to ask questions um as you
wish
so recent work that we've been involved
involved in
um started with looking at the housing
delivery test figures for february
2020 this was pre-covered
and we established that um weber had
achieved 123
of its target with a new figure of 416
houses
defined each year and mid-suffolk had
achieved 99
of its targ of its target with a new
figure of 535
um so we didn't need a housing delivery
test action plan for legislative
purposes this year
and we were you might recall bringing
this item to scrutiny on the 25th of
march but that process was
interrupted by covid however we have
tried to
prepare in your appendices the
pre-covered and the current position
in july in appendices um
f and g in terms of looking at the
pipeline of housing delivery going
through
and i would refer you to paragraphs four
point
two one and four point two three which
give you some key facts
about housing delivery in 2018 19
and then housing delivery in 2019
and 20. um so the recommendation is that
the content of this report and the
appendices before you help to inform
the the scrutiny process and and
obviously
uh make any recommendations as you deem
appropriate thank you thank you
christine
i'm sure that there will be some
questions from members
um i'm going to go through the list of
members not
necessarily in alphabetical order and if
you would
if you have a question would you please
ask at the appropriate point
um and this is for questions it's not
for debate
so could i ask paul lekman young
please to ask any questions he may have
uh thank you thank you chair um i have a
question
regarding the paragraph 4.21 which
uh christine fellow just referred to i'd
like to understand
the relationship between the total
number of outstanding permissions
and the the the uh calculated
five-year housing supply i i don't quite
see
the relationship of these two figures
and i guess there ought to be one
that's my uh question for the moment
can i refer that question to uh
rob hobbs please
thank you rob okay yeah
thank you so um effectively the
five-year housing land supply
looks at what's known as deliverable
sites whereas the um
total outstanding planning permissions
are deliverable and developable sites
they could come forward in years six to
ten or beyond that across the planned
period
the definition of deliverable is really
offering a suitable location for
development now
and it's achievable with a really
realistic prospect that housing will be
delivered on the site within five years
that provides the clarity
thank you uh councillor is that okay as
an answer
uh yes yes thank you chair
thank you can i move on to councillor
dave muller please
uh no questions at this stage thank you
chair thank you
councillor terence carter
yes thank you i have two questions to
ask first regards to
section five uh this is just
i know it's just be following themes but
i am assuming that the themes are not in
order priority he's been housing
economy being seconds environments and
strong healthy communities
and the second question would be on
section 11
environmental implications um
i do wonder when taken on a individual
case i assume the if the
environment implication is accounted for
but when we are talking a
large number of developments at what
point does
it become a requirement to have a
environmental impact assessment
as when you are taking a large
development when you're
uh turnover of earth which absorbs a
great deal of carbon when you're taking
account for
the um
the equipment used to make it the
vehicles not that
i'd assume is there going to be a
greater environmental impact
than just say a
building being gun in the back in the
back garden
thank you councillor carter um tom
barker would you like to respond to that
please
um yes if that's okay um
so just to clarify in section five the
themes are absolutely not in priority
order
all of those themes are priorities for
the council
in terms of section 11 and the
environmental implications
that refers to the environmental
implications of this report
rather than the environmental
implications of
um the delivery of housing for example
which
is assessed during planning applications
and allocations and plan making and all
those other things
so just to confirm section five the
themes are
not in any priority order they are all
our priorities and
section 11. that refers solely to the
implications of this report
rather than housing delivery per se
across a broader
broader issue thank you very much have
you any other questions councillor
carter
um no other questions at this moment
thank you councillor
adrian osborne please
yes thank you mr chairman yet i have no
questions at this time
thank you thank you um
has counselor james caston arrived
i don't think so or counselor sean
dawson
now we'll move on to councillor jane
gould then please
thank you chair no questions at this
time thank you
councillor catherine grandin no
questions at this time thank you
council alistair mccraw
thank you chair um i have a sort of
question i think for rob hobbs
um and perhaps uh
perhaps tom barker um and it concerns
the preparation of the evidence base
uh that we've produced to give ourselves
these figures
and um and it seems to be quite robust
can i ask if
the preparation of these figures has
been figured in this is not strictly
related to this report but the subject
continues in another format
has this evidence been of use in
preparing our response
to the government white paper
consultations
on planning for the future since that's
currently on the table
hello
yes i'll come back to that counselor
yeah i mean the evidence base is is like
you say is what we we use um
in making any responses to to
consultation or in producing um other
documents
i mean in essence we we've got a report
going to council
um this week on planning changes to
planning current planning system where
the housing um
localizing knee figure is the standard
method is um
being proposed to be changed so we've
produced a response to that but that's
looking at the the new figure rather
than the supply
at the moment uh my concern was
fundamentally
whether the evidence gathered here was
applicable
to the new method of calculation um or
if we were literally
having to tear all the work that has
been and it's a massive amount of work
and it's much appreciated we've had the
extra
six months or so figures um has that
sort of literally been
is that going to be thrown on the scrap
heap or has it still got validity
no the evidence is still um validity um
what the government's proposing to do is
update the standard method through the
planning practice guidance
and when that comes into effect and that
will be the new requirements that all
the evidence that goes into the supply
will not be discarded
thank you thank you councillor keith
scarf
thank you chair um page 55 and 56 refer
to
um surveys that we done with key
stakeholders
um large building um companies
small house builders etcetera um
obviously due to coving we weren't able
to have
uh a really effective engagement
exercise
in march the um update shows that we're
planning to have
virtual meetings uh are all
they're going to be considered and
discussed with the leads uh which i'm
presuming are the officers
do we have any idea when they will take
place because obviously that's
sort of six months plus a go uh and
obviously
i think we need a better engagement
process
thank you thank you
perhaps i can help with that uh members
i have engaged with work stream leads
and we are intending to hold a
stakeholder engagement in
january 2021 which will
uh happen before any new housing
delivery test figures
um are issued thank you
um anyone else got any more questions
i've got a couple of questions but if
any other members have got
um members of the committee you've got
any further questions
please raise a hand uh councillor
grandin
thank you um chair i
i noticed that such meetings are now
being held virtually
if the um kovid situation
is the same as it is currently
should there also be an option to do
meetings in a person-to-person
way face-to-face way uh in a
controlled environment in
uh large enough spaces and so on um
do you not think they might be more
effective um
now that things are beginning to open up
well hopefully they are
depending on what happens in the next
few weeks um
is that something that could be just
considered
john barker um yes
just for one moment if i can go back to
um councillor scarf's query and that
just to say that there is engagement
with the house building industry on an
ongoing basis so what um the report
refers to is a kind of formal event
um but that engagement with the industry
is is ongoing on a
on a permanent basis and just coming to
councillor grandin's
question um i i'm assuming that what you
were describing was that engagement with
the industry and whether that should be
happening face-to-face
or happening virtually one of the things
that we've experienced is that the
industry really quite like
the virtual meetings cuts down on travel
time and it means that we can
have conversations with regional
representatives of major house builders
for example
without drawing them out from cambridge
or or elsewhere where they might be
located so
the the virtual um meetings that we have
um tend have tended to be quite
effective
um and where we're pulling together a
number of
stakeholders i think teams is becoming
more normalized now
and you can you can meet with up to 45
or so
and i guess conscious that we're due an
announcement
in just over an hour's time from um
the two lead members of public health
england so
um i think the suggestion that we're out
of the water yet
in terms of um social distance and
requirements and such like
might be a bit premature um so we'll see
what those announcements
are this morning but we we have just to
give confidence
um officers have experienced really high
degrees of effectiveness using
virtual um interaction with house
builders agents and other
other developers i know persimmon
sorry can you hear me um i know
persimmon
for example are have been in their
offices for a while and i had a meeting
with them at their offices
and um that they
were finding it more comfortable doing
face to face
i um i have had a an email from
persimmon
um to meet with ian hamilton and um
they have suggested that they would like
to meet in their offices um
i'll i'll pick that up i think probably
around lunchtime and
see quite where we're at in terms of
anything further in the difference
yes thank you very much thank you i've
got three short questions but they are
all linked
um um i guess ideally we would
have completions at or just above the
target figure year after year
um what happens if we've got a sawtooth
effect of
completions well above target one year
below next year and so on um
and also if we deliver above target for
two or three years might government use
that as a
a as a way of raising the target
um and the other question is
are there sufficient smaller homes and
bungalows coming forward and if not what
can we do about it
who'd like to take that one um
yeah um councilwoman takes only the
first
two questions so you're talking about
the completions figure
um just also we'd like to caveat this
year's completions we didn't do our
usual on-site checks that we normally do
which um often um yeah strengthen the
completions figure
because of the covet situation um but
notwithstanding that
um you could well see completions above
target one year below target
and next year and which is why the
housing delivery test looks at a three
year average
and um in terms of your question around
um going
forward um currently as of the housing
delivery test um the next one
that is undertaken at the end of this
year the target will be 75
would be the threshold to pass the test
um so we're still
yeah doing well compared to that in
terms of your um question about the um
target in in general or the requirements
um
that's effectively as we talked earlier
about the standard method that's based
on affordability ratio so
um what you should see is the more homes
you build the um the
lower the requirement would be as a
result of the affordability ratio
improving
thank you in terms of um bungalows
um we do monitor um completions of
smaller homes and bungalows i'm unable
to give an exact figure at the moment
but
they are delivered i don't know if one
of my colleagues won't say anything
further on that
on this the last part of that question
was if if we're not getting enough
smaller homes and bungalows
is there some action that we can take
presumably that's not within the the the
actions of the
um uh the housing delivery test action
plan
certainly um uh when applications come
forward for planning permission um
you know we do look at housing need we
do address
housing need through um the level of
affordable housing
um that are brought forward and we do
discuss
uh other general need but
quite often the market uh brings forward
what is saleable so there is a balance
to be struck
uh in there i don't know if heather
wants to add anything
further to that or lou
yes certainly christine thank you um we
do try and negotiate with
developers with regards to bungalows but
they are something that are
more difficult to bring forward due to
the space they take up and the cost
implications on the viability of the
model but
it's certainly something we do we do
work towards
um as a wider piece of work we have been
looking at
um trying to develop through the suffolk
housing board
um understanding exactly what the needs
of both older persons and
those who may have specialist
accommodation requirements might be
we started that work off just as kind of
covered here and we went into lockdown
and
so um that work did sort of pause for a
short time but we're hoping to pick that
up again
and develop a suffolk wide strategy so
we understand exactly what that housing
need will be
in the longer term thank you council
repping
you were next i think and then and then
tom barker
uh thank you it's a follow-up to the
question you've just asked and the
responses we've just had
um so i the sort of philosophy seems to
be that the
requirement for older folks is to have
bungalows but
having lived and traveled around the
world this is not the only way
in which uh older people uh
accommodation can be catered for and i
just wonder if we
look at multi-tenancy type blocks
for accommodation in this regard
thank you tom barker do you want to
respond to
to that and the previous questions you
had your hand up earlier
uh yes i was just going to just going to
pick up i mean heather and christine
have largely covered it in terms of
bungalows and smaller homes
of course in terms of our own
development team and our own development
options
that is something that we will look at
and so for example as councils the very
first house that was completed
as part of the council's house building
in about 2017
um was a wheelchair accessible bungalow
on the basis that the market wasn't
delivering that type of housing and so
the option does exist for the council
itself
to seek to deliver some of those
types of development that the market
isn't effectively delivering
and picking up the final point um
absolutely yes it would be remiss of us
to assume that every
older person wants to live in a bungalow
or that a bungalow is necessarily
appropriate for all older people and so
[Music]
multi-block tenancies flats
other things um uh other products i
suppose that that
are appropriate for older people will
absolutely be part of our thinking
thank you uh kez rapping or your your
hand is still up
do you have another question thank you
and do do any members of
the committee have any more questions of
the offices please
in that case are there any other
counsellors present
who have any questions of the offices
please
if so please raise a hand in the usual
way
no so thank you
i will i'll now open the item for debate
and ask you in turn for your comments
so i shall i shall go around in some
order
um councillor adrian osborne
thank you mr chairman um i've very
little to say on it i
i am um obviously with the
the changes that the government are
bringing in obviously that will affect
at some point uh our delivery of housing
and uh obviously the representation from
baber
i think will be very uh uh
pointed towards uh decision
one way or and on behalf of the whole of
the district
um other than that um
i can i can see the points the only
thing was that there was one question
brought up which was
to do with the amount of housing if you
don't
get to that amount of housing would you
would you still have would it still go
on to the next year because you haven't
delivered that sufficient amount of
housing
but i think that was answered well thank
you thank you
uh councillor jane gould
thank you mr chair um it's more by way
of comment
really which is that um it's not just
people of a certain age who may choose
to live in bungalows
um that people of all ages with other
disabilities may be choosing to live in
bungalows as well
um so just by way of throwing that
comment in really
thank you yes i i mean i would agree
with that there are some young families
who prefer bungalows because they just
don't have the stairs
but they may you know have ready access
onto a garden and so on
but it does seem to be that the cost and
the land take for each
bungalow is is a problem that makes
that makes them less attractive to to
families i guess
um councillor catherine grandin
thank you um actually it's a it is a
question
um would that be okay of course
um going back to what adrian osborne
um alluded to how does this impact
um the new um
announcements made by the government um
recently regarding planning
um oh robert hobbs would you like to
take that one watch on market robert
thank you
so so the new announcements um regarding
planning her out for consultation at the
moment the first consultation changes
the current planning system
um ends the first of october the
planning white paper 29th of october
um in respect of the um the five-year
housing land supply
um statements throughout the
consultation as i've previously alluded
to the standard method
would be updated for your planning
practice guidance and that could come
into effect once that planning practice
guides is
updated in terms of other measures
particularly through the planning white
paper they will require legislation
and there will be some way off so there
are traditional arrangements in place
for around for example for plan making
that are picked up through through that
answer this question thank you very much
thank you
councillor young
uh thank you chair um
one of the things i would say about the
papers for this meeting is that
certainly the reports seem to be
extremely exhaustive uh and i just
wondered actually
uh because i i'm kind of new to this
whether we could actually have some sort
of summary at the
at the beginning because there's a huge
amount of
detail to absorb and i think the
officers clearly are in a better
position to
summarize the work that they've done as
a an introduction to
to the reports um my second point
is that it would appear that the issue
of stalled site is
one of the preeminent issues that we
face with house building
but it's not entirely clear from reading
the report
exactly how we're going to try to
overcome this and i'd appreciate
officers uh speaking to that thank you
thank you um
tom is that one for you to take or
christine
shall i start and maybe tom can uh
pick up after um so we have been
looking at stalled sites and an appendix
f g you have got a summary of
of the flow of pipeline uh
development uh going through our system
so you can see
things starting off as outline
and at the end of the day uh towards the
right hand side of
of both the tables you can see what is
actually
uh under construction um looking back
at stalled sites as we did in a
a general sense um housing
infrastructure fund work that we did in
2017
we did make two bids for money to come
through to bring two sites forward one
of which was
failing from a viability point of view
in fact it was the only known viability
uh problem in mid-suffolk which was the
fison site
and we uh unfortunately having made
a housing infrastructure fund bid for
that um
it was unsuccessful julie abby taylor
was successful in attracting some
housing expertise to look at it
at a second stage but as you'll all be
aware uh the subject that the
the site was subject to fire damage and
that
fell away in respect of baber we did an
awful lot of work and are continuing to
work with the developers
we made a hif bid for ganges
which again failed for cost-benefit
reasons and we followed that up with
a housing infrastructure loan in order
to try and get
the site started but again there were
cost-benefit
reasons why that couldn't go ahead but i
do understand
that ganges is poised ready to start now
with all the conditioned discharge
uh happening we also did some work in
respect
of a site in the town center
in a stone market uh
which was ash's farm when we did a
development brief approach
and that has resulted ultimately in the
site-changing hand
and an application coming forward so we
we do look at stall sites from a
monitoring point of view and where
necessary we will work with those that
need help in order to bring sites
forward tom i don't know if you want to
add anything to that
um no i think that was that was fairly
comprehensive christine i think i i
suppose this is similar to the
the i think it was tolstoy every unhappy
family
and all happy families are alike and
every unhappy family is unhappy in its
own way
all all stalled sites are stalled in
their in their own individual
ways so developments move forward
because
the market supports it the land
availability is there the developer's
able to access finance the conditions
are written in a way that
allows sites to come forward um there
are no land constraints or contamination
that unearths itself at a later stage so
there's
there's any number of reasons why a site
may
not come forward at the pace with which
we anticipate and of course
um covid and all of the subsequent
implications from that
in terms of labor supply and material
supply and
market conditions will all play into the
issue of stalled sites
it is something that we've looked at and
the officers continue to look at
something that development management
are constantly seeking to do is to
ensure that they're not imposing
conditions
for example that make it difficult for
developers to get on site
and there's any number of other
conversations that that
that i might have with developers to see
if there's something that we can
help them to unlock that christine and
colleagues might look at in terms of
infrastructure provisional borrowing
and christine went into some depth on
the housing infrastructure fund
bids that we we sought to apply from we
also have an ongoing dialogue with
homes england um again to see if there
are particular
sites where they might be indeed might
be able to inject some some capital into
the site to help bring it forward
um there are inevitably those sites
where perhaps landowners fall out or
land changes hands um that
that then mean that different people
have different ambitions about
bringing sites forward and sometimes
they want to and sometimes
they would rather sit on them and
there's very little opportunity for us
if a developer doesn't want to bring a
site forward but if they do want to
bring a site forward then
we'll explore everything that we can to
help make that happen
um and one of the things that as
councils we've done that can sometimes
get in the way
um the finding a buyer for
the affordable housing elements of sites
can sometimes
uh be difficult and can
lead to a developer slowing down
development or or stopping
completely and one of the things that we
as councils have done over the past few
years
is to buy section 106 properties
off plan so to speak which has helped
some sites to move forward at greater
pace
thank you very much councillor keith
scarf
please thank you chair yeah i mean i'd
like to commend the officers for
uh the very detailed report um that
we've got before us today
i think it has helped to focus officers
minds to how we deliver housing within
both districts
and certainly a lot of progress has been
made so
many thanks to the officers uh for that
because one of the reasons sometimes why
sites are not developed quite as rapidly
as we would like
is of course if a developer builds too
many homes too quickly they flood the
market with homes of that type
and that lowers the price so that's
something you've always got to bear in
mind i think
you know developers have a reason
sometimes for not delivering
um quite at the speed that we would
perhaps like
because it's in their interests perhaps
not to may i suggest
um and that is something that whatever
we do
uh whatever the government do through
their white paper um
i think will be very difficult to
overcome i mean we have a large number
of
planning applications with approval in
both mid-suffolk
and baba and that is good because
obviously that's driven the numbers up
in terms of delivery of the housing on a
three-year rolling basis so i'd just
like to make those as comments
thank you very much councillor counselor
alastair mccraw
thank you chair i apologize for the
delay there
um i think the only
question really before us is looking at
the housing delivery
test action plans and starting from page
60 the babel one obviously i focused on
the babel one but actually
the two plans are virtually the same the
figures might vary
the approach taken it seems fairly
apparent to me that
they i'll say we've become more
practiced at this very practice to this
when i say we
actually i mean the officers have become
very practiced at this
and it shows um there's a clear
structure of
uh what the background is how the
analysis goes on
the different classes and types of
staller
how we monitor it how and the appendices
contain
some examples some definite data so the
only question really before this
committee
is if we can make any suggestions to
any changes or recommendations to any
changes
um to the test action plans
and i have to say i can't see any um
it's particularly relevant of course
that the whole process may
change but that change is not set in
stone it's a white
paper and as tom has suggested
this still requires primary legislation
it will take
time there are transitional arrangements
and i've looked at the
uh draft responses to uh both the white
paper
well the white paper that we've we've
prepared for for now
and i can see that we are not alone
in uh having some serious um questions
to ask about this and i believe that's
also being paralleled at westminster
um and amongst the mps of all groups
um this could be seen as something of a
knee-jerk reaction on ideological
grounds
we're not discussing that now but i'm
satisfied that we've got
a robust methodology we've got robust
figures and given the circumstances to
have come this far
um throughout covid and come up with a
recommendation
i would happily support the
recommendation that we note the plan
as it stands i can't really see that we
can offer any recommendations to improve
this
as i say this is not the first time
we've we've been to this particular
rodeo
and i would like to commend the officers
for their work
thank you very much um council terence
carter
uh yes um just to raise again on the a
point that's been made before regarding
the uh bungalows
i can certainly tell you on the social
housing
aspect uh bungalows for disabled
adaptations are
a very short supply they tend to go
as fast as they can on the market so
if we could be building more of those it
certainly would help out
on uh various different various of our
tenants
um i do it did also have a
sort of a query i do realize this is a
regarding the support
that the um the gain going back to the
environmental impact assessment
as we do know the number of houses that
we do require
as we do we can i assume do a report on
how
it would affect the regards to the
turnover of
land regards the amount of excess
vehicles on the streets for
doing the developments uh or i can just
do
like possibly we could do a report on
the environmental app
impact we are taking on a development as
a scale of a number of houses per year
that we need to develop uh
granted i assume this may be something
that might be taken upon by the
environmental forum but it might be it
might be
useful for when we are doing uh they're
trying to
tackle tackle amount of excess carbon
per year due to these developments
um yeah thank you for those comments but
i don't i don't think that the
housing delivery test action plan is a
vehicle for
checking out the environmental
implications
of various
separate developments or the development
of
land in totality i think that is a
matter for
the planning applications at the
appropriate time
and at a higher level i think for the
joint local plan um
i think i've answered the question
rather than add it to the debate but
does anybody else
do any of the offices want to add to
that
um councilman mccrory you'd like to say
something i'd just like to concur that
that's not the purpose of the test
action plan because those are separate
matters
and we're just this is a a calculation
um and that supply and yes it's a it's a
laudable concern but it's not the
appropriate to this report that's all
yeah thank you very much um
councillor muller i think you're the
last person on the list
yeah thank you thank you chair i totally
agree with all the comments that have
been made and particularly
what counselor crawl said so i would
actually be happy to propose that we
moved the recommendation as stated in
the papers
thank you chair uh thank you for that
can we just look carefully at the
wording of
the um the recommendation before i ask
for a second
because i just wondered whether it would
be improved by saying
then the contents of this report and
appendices together with the verbal
contributions
to the overview and script or at the
overview of scrutiny committee
rather than just by witnesses because i
think that
everything that everyone has said is
worthy of consideration
um and we we didn't have a
um a panel of witnesses giving us um
their views so um can i go back to you
counselor
muller and ask if you would be content
to
slightly alter the wording um and and in
three one
um and consider whether or not
uh you want to include three two because
i think the general feeling is we don't
have any
separate recommendations but what we
would like
is to support um
the the plan and ask that as it
as it is as it moves forward that the
views
that have been expressed here are taken
into account
can i can i ask councillor if he would
be content with that
yes i'm completely happy with that uh
thank you chair
thank you councilmember councilman
right we have a proposal we have a
seconder um
i think what we now need to do
is carry out a roll call so can i ask
the
the governance officer if she will take
a roll call vote
thank you certainly chair
please reply with four against abstain
when you ask your name
council terence carter
four uh councillor grandin
four uh councillor gold
four councillor mccraw
four council muller
four council osborne
four councillor scarf paul
councilwell four and council epcon young
four uh
that is a unanimous chair thank you very
much and thank you to the officers for
an
excellent report and a lot of work
that's been done
on this topic throughout covid and and
before and since
so thank you very much indeed
we now move on to agenda item nine
on the agenda um
this is the annual review of the joint
homes and housing strategy and
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping reduction strategy
2019 to 20 2024
and i believe councillor jan osborne
would like to introduce
this item and then heather tucker the
corporate manager for housing solutions
will introduce the report so can i
invite councillor jan osborne to speak
please
thank you mr chairman good morning
members uh good morning
i am delighted to be able to introduce
to you for consideration and scrutiny
today
paper j o s stroke 1940
annual review of the joint homes and
housing strategy and homelessness
reduction and rough sleeping strategy
2019-2024
in march 2019 members of all political
parties unanimously approved
the adoption of the first joint homes
and housing strategy
and joint homelessness reduction and
rough sleeping strategy
these strategies commit us to be open
and transparent
providing information on how we are
performing against the strategic aims
set out within the two documents so as
part of adoption
a commitment was made to report back to
overview and scrutiny committee
for an annual review and update to all
members
this is the first annual review of the
progress made
against the strategies it has been
slightly delayed
due to the impact of the pandemic and in
future years we propose to
the review is carried out in june or
july of each year
today i ask that members review and note
the contents of this report and
appendices
along with verbal contributions heather
tucker
our corporate manager for housing
solutions who has responsibility for the
implementation of both of these
strategies
is with us today and will now provide
you with a presentation
which shows the progress to date the
actions
currently underway and the future
actions planned over the remaining
four years of the strategy thank you mr
chairman
thank you thank you council osborne
thank you chair
i'm going to share my screen if that's
okay so bear me one moment i've got a
presentation just to to give you this
morning
right can you all see the screen is that
worked okay yes
it has yes thank you brilliant super so
thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity to present to you today
an update on the implementation of the
joint homes and housing strategy
the housing strategy was adopted in
march 2019
with nine strategic aims and 112
associated actions
much progress has been made in the first
year with many actions planned over the
coming years
to ensure the strategies are effectively
delivered
some of the highlights include an
uplifting affordable housing delivery to
exceed our annual targets
a continued reduction in void turnaround
times and successful bidding for
homelessness funding
there has been some disruption to some
aspects of delivery due to staff changes
and many of the actions have been
reviewed to become
smart we have developed a new project
management approach to ensuring progress
is maintained
and as part of this presentation today i
would like to give you a high level
overview of what has been delivered
against each of the aims to date
what work is currently underway and what
work is planned
i'm providing a high level overview
conscious that it would be a very long
process to discuss all 112 actions
individually
i'd also like to update take the
opportunity to update you on the
potential impact
covid has had on the delivery of these
strategies
i will ensure that these slides are
circulated with the minutes at the end
of the meeting
due to showing my screen i cannot
necessarily see when someone has got
their virtual hand raised
so if it's okay with you i will take any
questions at the end
so the first aim is that the housing
market functions effectively providing
homes which are as affordable as
possible
to meet the needs of residents and
support the local economy
in regards to what has been delivered as
councils we went out to consultation on
the first
full draft of the joint local plan
during july to september last year
this included holding many events across
the districts to try and encourage local
residents to actively participate in the
process
during the last financial year 114
affordable
homes were completed in baber which was
a significant
increase on the previous year when over
52 were delivered
128 homes last year were delivered in
mid-suffolk which is a slight increase
on 118
in 1819 since 2017
89 units have been added to baber's
council housing stock
and 65 to mid suffolks this is a mixture
of new builds
section 106 purchases and street
purchases
we've also established a new pre-action
advice process to help developers bring
forward better proposals
some of the work in progress includes
amendments and updates to the joint
local plan
continuing to secure more default
affordable housing via section 106
and the redevelopment of the former hq
sites which will provide 94 homes in
needham market
and 57 in hadley some of the planned
work includes adding a further 189 units
to babies housing stock
and 233 to mid suffix
aim 2 there is a wide and varied choice
of good quality sustainable homes of
different sizes
types and tenures to meet the needs of a
wide range of different households
there has been some really positive work
around this area particularly in
relation to our work with community land
trusts
lavender community land trust is already
working alongside baber
hasto and suffolk county council been
able to deliver 18 properties with more
plans
east bergholt has also set up their clt
and is currently looking for its first
potential dwellings
in mid suffolk we now have three
community land trusts and a further two
in progress are being set up these are
in stradbroke
i elmswell lacks field and mendelssohn
we also now have a full-time officer in
post who is dedicated to working with
community housing development which is
fantastic for us
we have created an enhanced housing
stock database which we are continuing
to update as we complete stock condition
surveys of our stock
and we are also reviewing our garage
sites and considering what opportunities
there may be for some of them in the
future
including redevelopment
aim three there is a wide and varied
choice of good quality
sustainable homes of different sizes
types and tenures
to meet the needs of a wide range of
different households
oh sorry i've just read the same one
again so bear with me aim three
homelessness is prevented and our
services provide positive and planned
interventions
there have been some significant
achievements in homelessness since the
implementation of the strategy
sits alongside the homes and housing
strategy it's a homelessness reduction
and rough sleeping strategy
this aim links those two strategies
together
some of the key achievements include the
launch of central suffolk lettings
which now means we are able to offer a
guaranteed rent scheme to private
landlords
we have also converted three properties
in baber district to provide an
additional 17 units of temporary
accommodation
in january this year we found out we had
been successful
in our bid to extend our supported
lettings team which provides support to
former russ sleepers to prevent them
from returning to the streets
we were also successful in a partnership
bid with west suffolk for a rough
sleeper outreach service to be developed
in our districts full time
more recently only last week we found
that we have successfully secured one
hundred thousand pounds
to help ensure there is accommodation
available over the winter months
to prevent anyone sleeping rough
particularly during this pandemic
we are also working in partnership with
other local councils and health to
develop a new approach to ending rust
sleeping for good
we've also submitted a further bid to
the ministry for housing communities and
local government
which we await the outcome of but if
successful it means we'll be able to
develop our own supported housing scheme
which will offer high support 24 7 to
prevent rough sleepers from returning to
the streets
aim four baby mid suffolk is an
effective social landlord
known for delivering quality services
i'm sure having been very involved in
this area previously you'll be really
pleased to hear that void turnaround
times have continued to reduce further
in 2019-20 void days were 17
in baber and 19 in mid-suffolk both of
which were within our 21-day target
which is a fantastic achievement
we also now have our own tenant board
which works alongside us to support the
development of quality services
we have completed a star satisfaction
survey of residents
and are now in the process of
implementing the recommendations
aim five homes in high quality
sustainable environments
served by jobs and community facilities
appropriate green space
effective transport links and other
necessary infrastructure
we have allocated over one million
pounds worth of sale funding in baber
and almost four million in mid suffolk
including 2.4 million towards the
expansion of starkland high school
we are supporting the development of the
suffolk design process and will also be
considering the potential
for installing electric car charging
points within our housing estates
the strategy is also being aligned
alongside the environment strategy to
ensure a joined up approach to meeting
environmental challenges we are facing
aim six the best use is made of private
sector land and private accommodation
across the districts we have returned
four properties back into use which have
been empty for more than two years
we also issued 17 grants to landlords to
improve the standard of rental
properties
we are currently developing a new model
for disabled facilities grants which is
due to commence in december this year
we have also conducted a review of the
private sector housing service and have
developed a plan for how we want to grow
and develop the service over the next
couple of years
aim 7 people live in vibrant and
well-connected communities
and homes and communities continue to
meet the changing needs of residents
we now have offices working with
integrated neighbourhood teams to ensure
that health
housing and care services are
coordinated
we are carrying out a review of our
housing register work
and how it works and operates although
this has been delayed slightly to
covered 19
it is planned over the next 12 months we
are also planning to carry out a piece
of work through the suffolk housing
board to gain a greater understanding
county-wide
of the housing needs of older and
vulnerable people
aim 8 everyone has a suitable home and
residents are able to live as
healthfully
safely and independently as possible
within sustainable communities
we have installed over 500 heat pumps in
council properties
290 in baber and 254
in mid suffolk we have also supported
this
establishment of dementia action
alliances in hadley lavenham
stone market and i and are now
supporting the launch of one in sudbury
aim nine both councils have strong
relationships with residents
developers and other partners that
ensure we
that enable us to deliver housing
infrastructure and services effectively
and to innovate where appropriate five
neighborhood plans have been developed
in baber and ate in mid-suffolk and
offices are currently working with 23
parishes in baby
and 17 in mid-suffolk to either prepare
or amend
neighborhood plans we want to look to
secure resources to deliver more
improvements to the public realm areas
of our council housing stock areas
and we had planned to carry out some
developer developer engagement events
which unfortunately had to be cancelled
due to the covid 19 restrictions
however we are now looking at how this
may be able to be done virtually to
prevent any further delays
there has been some impact of covid on
the strategies
but we're still very early on in the
process of these strategies having only
adopted them
18 months ago which gives us plenty of
time to catch back up again
and deliver all of our objectives
covid has put a significant pressure on
the delivery of homelessness
and we were given some extremely
ambitious targets by the government of
getting everyone in
within 24-hour period which has put an
increased demand on the service
however it has also given us a fantastic
opportunity to work more collaboratively
with other local partners including
the other districts and bubbas the
county council and health including the
clinical commissioning groups
and we are looking now at how we can end
our sleeping for good across suffolk
as i've already mentioned we've recently
secured a hundred thousand pounds to
help us with accommodation costs over
the winter months
inevitably as a result of the pandemic
there is some national uncertainty in
the housing
market this has been well documented and
we're unsure of exactly what the
long-term impact is at the moment
however when restrictions were eased
builders did get back on site and many
developments are now proceeding
we have had some challenges around how
we can do home visits and deliver some
of the repairs and improvements to
people's homes
during the pandemic this was based on
government guidance around whether or
not we're allowed to enter properties
only in
kind of like emergency situations
hopefully this is a short-term
impact and during the pandemic we
actually did a great deal of proactive
work looking at how we can utilize
technology
and we've recently adopted a new system
which means we can actually
contact residents with their mobile
phones and actually
access their cameras and they're able to
show us their repairs in their home
without us necessarily needing to go in
so when we do go
we make sure we're going with all the
right equipment and parts to be able to
do the job straight away
we also managed to clear a backlog of
more than six thousand outstanding
repair job tickets
um covered has and will for some time
being
um affect the way that we engage with
our communities
um however we're holding virtual
meetings with organizations such as
community land trusts and developers
and there may be some challenges around
how consultations for neighborhood plans
and referendums will be affected
but at the moment we haven't actually
progressed with those and we wait to see
you know how things change over the
coming months
very aware of obviously the climate
change and the environment strategy that
has been adopted by
both councils and we want to make sure
we develop a strategic approach to
mitigating and adapting to the climate
change
there's a number of areas within this
strategy that align with the environment
strategy
and so officers are spending lots of
time looking at how we can make sure
they're joined up
for the council's own development and
acquisitions um
we're currently looking at how we set a
rolling three to five year pipeline
so that members can continually
scrutinize that process and we're also
setting up a new design specification
for our own new builds
so the next steps for the homes and
housing strategy and the homelessness
reduction and rust sleeping strategy
we have developed a programme board over
the last year which
oversees the development of these
strategies it includes key offices
and managers from various aspects of the
housing
and planning service we review regularly
the progress to date
we scrutinize internally ourselves what
work has been done and what work needs
to be done
to make sure that we're on target to
deliver what we expect
we as well as the housing and homes and
housing strategy being referred to in
the corporate plan
we're also making sure it's in all
relevant service area plans
in various aspects of the business and
also making sure it is set in people's
objectives making sure there is that
golden thread throughout the whole
organization thank you for giving me the
opportunity to talk about the update
the progress um on the strategies today
today
unfortunately as councillor osborne
explained this was slightly delayed due
to the impact of the pandemic i hope in
future years to be able to bring this to
you earlier in the summer
but hopefully this has been a helpful
update i'm now more than happy to take
any questions and i will stop sharing my
screen as well
thank you very much heather um it was an
excellent report an
excellent presentation a lot of detail
in there
so i'm sure we're all very grateful
for that um i'm going to go
i'm going to go around not in
alphabetical order but everyone will get
a turn
um and um
well i see i see hands are raised i'll
i'll take those three first but you
don't need to raise a hand because i
will come to everybody
in due course um
so i've got a list here i'm going to go
i'm going to use this list but i will
come to you all i promise you
um right uh councillor catherine grandin
please
thank you um i thought that's a really
excellent report heather
and jan so um you know well done on that
and for all that you've achieved going
this time um
i was particularly pleased to see um
how the repairs have
been tackled and with hopefully just one
visit now
because of using technology and cameras
and so on it seems very sensible
but my question i have a couple of
questions um
i had thought or at least i i seem to
recall hearing
um or being told that we were very
fortunate
certainly in baber anyway i'm not sure
about with suffolk that we
didn't have any rough sleepers in our
area
i seem to hear that um remember being
told that at council meetings and
thinking oh
you know that felt quite proud of that
now i do
understand that some people may have
been sleeping on sofas and that
um those people that their situations
may have changed
but it seems to me that all of a sudden
when um
the pandemic happened we needed a lot of
hotel space and it seems that we need a
lot of
ongoing accommodation for rough sleepers
how can we go from having no requirement
at one stage not so long ago to suddenly
needing this lot much larger
ongoing requirement uh please could you
answer that
certainly councillor grandin um yeah i
mean historically we did have
very few rough sleepers within the um
within both council areas in fact and if
we did find a rust sleeper we're able to
engage with them very promptly
and find them accommodation and get them
off the streets
unfortunately we started to see um a
rise in rust sleeping at the beginning
of the year
um and then when the pandemic um
actually kind of took effect and we had
the lockdown situation
we found a significant number of people
that were staying with
friends or relatives and quite transient
and i think as you mentioned you know
sofa surfing where they do go from place
to place
actually that became untenable because
people weren't supposed to be
moving from place to place they were
meant to be having one home of their own
actually a number of people weren't
willing for you know a friend to stay or
relatives to stay
um if you know if that wasn't their
permanent home they were sleeping on the
sofa so we did see a significant
increase in single people needing
accommodation
you also the other thing we found was
that actually some people that are still
going out to work
but actually living with maybe elderly
relatives who were concerned about the
impact of covert and the risk of that
person bringing the infection in
and actually it meant they they were
being asked to leave so
we did see a significant increase and
unfortunately we have seen
um higher numbers of rough sleepers in
the last few months than we've seen ever
within our districts
um and we do still have a number of
people out on the streets at the moment
that we're trying to engage with
and try and get them into accommodation
it is a challenge with with rough
sleeping
it's no quick solution and that's why
we've put this bid forward to the
government for some additional funding
to help us cover um support costs to put
intensive support in place to try and
prevent
individuals from returning to the
streets unfortunately there's normally a
whole multitude of reasons why
somebody's actually
sleeping it's never just one cause or
one issue
so actually trying to you know ensure we
get the right support in place and have
the ability to do that is is certainly a
challenge so
we have put this bid forward through the
next steps accommodation program
and we're hopeful we might know the
outcome within the next couple of weeks
you've actually answered my sort of
supplementary question as well because i
know that
um or i understand that uh people in
that position quite often have other
problems perhaps drug problems or family
issues
so when you say um
the support is that the kind of support
that you're referring to
that we bring in that kind of support to
help them
perhaps hopefully in the future no
longer need
our home support
yeah absolutely counsellor i mean
there's many many aspects to support and
there's many different specialists that
can provide
support in a particular aspect for
example um drug and alcohol recovery
outreach service doing a fantastic job
in regards to drugs and alcohol
we have the health outreach project who
we work with who are funded by the
clinical commissioning groups
who go out and look at the health of
rough sleepers many
um rust sleepers won't actually be
engaged with primary
health services they might not have a gp
they might not be able to access
day-to-day health care services so
the health outreach project go out and
and work with individuals and engage
with them to make sure they have to
access things like the medications they
need
there's then the kind of wider more
holistic kind of support element which
is around
ensuring someone's tenancy ready so you
can't you know just accommodating
someone and putting them in
accommodation if they haven't held an
accommodation before
and have lived a very transient
lifestyle it can be really hard for them
to actually be able to maintain that
tenancy so we talk to them about things
like how to set up utility bills how to
budget their money
how to apply for benefits how to access
reasonably priced furniture all sorts of
things so there's many aspects to
support
but we hope if we're successful with our
bid that we'll be able to put intensive
support in 24 7 with night staff as well
so um that's often the time when people
struggle most
um during the day when you know many
support services are open it's less open
at night so by having a 24-hour support
service we hope that will limit the
number of people returning to the
streets
thank you very much heather um thank you
this guy i think you
you would like to add to that and then
councillor jan osborne
thank you uh councillor welling um it's
just on the point of
homelessness and rough sleeping during
the pandemic and i just want to bring
members attention to the work that was
done
on behalf of all suffolk authorities and
their partner agencies including
police probation health and so on um
just to to inform uh members that during
the pandemic we
housed um in the short term more than
200
individuals that were presenting as
rough sleeping
um suffolk authorities uh took an
approach which was collaborative um and
in partnership and and one thing that we
did recognize was that
actually what we needed to do was
develop policies and strategies
um around actually ensuring that
everyone that had come in
as part of that everyone in campaign
actually found uh housing in the long
term and actually we eradicated
rough sleeping work has been going on
we have developed a evidence base we
have developed a
prospectus and a draft strategy
and myself and colleagues are working
with uh suffolk public sector leaders
and uh suffolk chief execs uh to to
finesse those documents and to
to try and drive those forward and bring
those forward in
in suffolk um and that will be based on
some of the evidence that has already
seen elsewhere in suffolk around
a housing uh first model so i just want
to provide some reassurance to members
that actually
there's a significant amount of work
being done uh at a county level but
being uh heavily supported by
officers from baber and mid-suffolk
thank you gavin councillor
coaster jan osborne yeah thank you mr
chairman actually
um heather and gavin have already said
what
most of what i was going to say what i
will add to that is
obviously rough sleeping and
homelessness has many many challenges
one of those key challenges is helping
those tenants to sustain a tenancy when
they do get it eventually
so that we can ensure they stay within
that home for the rest of their lives or
however long they need that
that home for and that challenge becomes
really where we need that uh that
supported housing element which we
haven't got access to
at the moment or i haven't got full
access to at the moment
so i'm really really hoping and i'm
confident in heather and her team that
we will be successful
in that further bid where from the
government we can go and get that
funding
to ensure that those tenants that we do
place
in our home have that support there that
they require 24
7. can i just add as well that the team
under gavin and heaven's direction have
done a fantastic
job um both during coved prior to covid
and continuing beyond so i would just
like to
take this opportunity to add my thank
you to
to the team thank you mr chairman thank
you councillor osborne uh
councillor mccraw and then i'm going on
to councillor muller
i just wanted to add something to uh
uh catherine's point about uh rough
sleepers
that in previous years i recall that
when we carried out
our surveys that we were unable to
record those people who did not wish to
be recorded
and obviously with the kovid 19
situation that situation no longer
replied because it was an emergency
situation
everybody realized that so we had in the
past
perhaps some false figures uh we knew
that there were rough sleepers within
the districts
but of course the statistics did not
show them because for reasons of
personal privacy or whatever
so uh they were perhaps a little bit
misleading i would just thought i'd
mention that
thank you very much councilman mccorl um
councillor muller
uh thank you chair um firstly i would
like to thank heather for
her excellent presentation which is
really interesting and i'd also really
like to follow on from uh councillor
grandin's comments about russ sleepers
um i've certainly noticed four rust
sleepers in stone mark and i'm sure my
stone market colleagues have noticed the
same
i wonder whether heather outside this
meeting perhaps via email could perhaps
give the stone market district
councillors
an update of what is happening with the
rough sleepers in stone market please
thank you and yes councilman happy to
contact you about the meeting
um if i can just also come back on
councilman mccaul's point as well if
that would be okay please chair
certainly and in regards to previous
figures in previous years there's a
difference between those that are
homeless and safer surfing and those are
actually
sleeping so every year that all councils
in the country have to do a snapshot on
one particular night in time
normally around mid-november where you
have to look at how many rough sleepers
you have at that night
it's quite specific wording which i
haven't got in front of me but it's
basically
an individual which is believed to be
and prepared to be bedding down that
night in an outside space
we know and we you know all councils
across the country have a huge number of
sofa surfers who will go from place to
place
but they're not classed as a rust
sleeper because they're not actually
bedding down outside they're they're
transient in their
in their nature of having accommodation
but they're not actually bedding down
outside
um we have you know been very fortunate
in previous years we've seen very very
very few
individuals with sleep which is one of
the reasons why we've never really
qualified for much government funding
before
i think it's um you know it's really
interesting that when the pandemic first
hit the government looked at rough
sleeper numbers across the country
and allocated each council an amount of
money to help them with accommodating
known rust leaps during the pandemic for
each council we got 1
650 pounds which is very a very small
amount and doesn't go very far to
actually you know covering many nights
of accommodation
however we we put quite a strong bid
together for the ministry
um for housing communities local
government as part of the interim
accommodation needs for the winter and
we really evidenced the challenges we'd
faced and
the number of sofa surfers that had kind
of come forward and the
demand we'd had for accommodation we
actually accommodated 38 people in babe
mid suffolk that ordinarily we would not
have owed a housing duty to
um and i think it's testament that you
know by putting that evidence into that
bid that's why we've now been awarded
that one hundred thousand
thank you councillor mccraw did you want
to add
to that and then they said
i think it just demonstrates the
difficulties of methodology
and and uh and definitions uh of these
things
that there are multiple definitions but
when you have a crisis like kervid19
you actually have an opportunity to
tackle a long-standing problem
and give it some real teeth and i have
to say that
what heather and and gavin and the rest
of the team have done on this
subject has been remarkable not least of
which was
bringing uh properties into use in a
matter of a single weekend
that is just beyond normal praise that
is
above and beyond the call of duty and
and this is something that we'd like to
see continue in the future
obviously thank you uh
gavin fisk you you had another point
thank you chad
thank you i don't want to to labor the
point around rough sleeping conscious
that this items around the whole housing
strategy but i think it's just important
uh to know as another example of the
work that's been done
as a result of covert in a very very
quick time
and which supplements and supports the
aims of the housing strategy
that we have in front of you today so
for example just around rough sleeping
we now have in suffolk as a result of
covid
a rough sleeping tool which allows all
of the partner agencies to capture
those individuals that are known to be
rough sleeping
beyond that it now starts to capture
needs
um and current circumstances of those
individuals and the expectation is that
this tall
will now in in going forward support the
commissioning of new services
so where we started to develop and
identify that individuals have
a specific need for example around uh
alcohol misuse or drug misuse
actually this will now start to develop
solutions
and just to reassure members this all of
this work has been developed as a result
of covid
and all of the sharing information
sharing protocols have been put in place
with all of the partner agencies to
allow this
level of sharing which actually was
never seen before
uh covered thank you very much
uh councillor carter can i remind people
this is still questions it's not debate
uh yes thank you um i did i'd be very
interested to see
the um records as
as to how effective affordable housing
is that prevent
homelessness is this widely debated
within circles of
crisis and shelter to actually how much
it alleviates
uh how much of actually it's uh
it's very widely debated um
but would be interesting though also
uh which other um
which outside bodies were involved in
business because uh
in a recent report by ihack i believe
the uh
the british housing so i think uh
the just before quite a bit but they
said
a great deal of issue regards rough
sleeping
it was the lack of accommodation and
halfway housing in the area where
they in suffolk is a a great deal for
where they need uh help with drug abuse
uh not be able to find it in the uh in
suffolk and therefore
if they not be able to keep a tendency
uh
due to being too far out away from
their homes into local support networks
so i i did wonder if there's any any
work with them and either outside bodies
such as
crisis and shelter um have gone into
risk report
um that's just just a couple of just a
question regardless actually
but it's a very great indeed to report
it does uh it shows what can be done
for code but it just doesn't really show
the long term of this once things return
to
a new normal so it does it doesn't it
makes me wonder how um
how long this is going to affect for
rough sleeping and how
whether a problem will resurface again
when it becomes yet again
an issue that can be so easily swept
under the carpet
thank you for the question gavin i think
this is really a question about who's
involved in the suffolk wide
project yeah i'm certainly happy to
to answer in part heaven may want to
come in um as well
i think council carter's question
touched on
the support for rough sleepers and i
think we've already discussed some of
the work that's gone on
certainly within the baby mid suffolk
districts we had identified that uh
prior to covid
certain uh parts of the outreach service
was unavailable or unaccessible actually
again and i think we have to use covert
as the example
because clearly it's been the catalyst
for
adapting and involving more agencies and
expanding
uh the role and and remit and resource
so
um i'd expect those conversations to be
ongoing um
and for the level of commissioning of
services to
be provided so that actually um
there is no difference uh no matter
where you are living um in suffolk
um i think just to touch on um
accommodation um
accommodation is is is obviously um
a finite supply we can have the
conversation whether it be around
rough sleeping or earlier in your debate
uh this morning you were having
the discussions around housing demand
and the number of
homes available certainly what babe and
suffolk have done
over the past two years it has doubled
our temporary accommodation um for those
that are
uh homeless um that has prevented um
uh any large numbers of individuals
being placed in bed and breakfast way
or out of the district which i think is
a a real positive
um and we've also been working with
registered providers
uh to uh seek their support their
endorsement and their commitment
to um accessing some of their own stock
um for the needs of those that are
homeless um but heather may want to
expand on that
thanks gavin um yeah i mean i think it's
also um important to note that it's not
just a statutory services
we engage with a part of this rough
sleeping work so
there was um you know many individuals
from districts brothers health
and public health in the meetings but
actually we've also held separate
meetings with the voluntary sector as
well which included ihag
anglia care trust and organization
organizations such as that
and we're also doing a lot of work at
the moment with the county council
around the housing related support
contract
um and looking at how that would be
commissioned in the future and that's
the contract that commissions supported
housing for individuals
um and we've learned a lot we've already
done a review of that ahead of the
pandemic and we'd learned a lot around
actually what we felt future need needed
to look like
but actually as a result of the pandemic
we've learned even more and so we're now
honing that kind of process and looking
at what the future commissioning model
might look like
um but we are aware of lots of the
organizations and we do work incredibly
well with them we've been able to you
know bring new services forward but
i think it's important to note that you
know a huge amount of work has been done
in regards to homelessness since the
pandemic started
but it's not just since the pandemic
started the team are constantly
achieving huge amounts of positive
interventions
to prevent homelessness we've brought
lots of new things forward
such as the guaranteed rent scheme
excuse me last year brought forth the
homeless prevention fund
as an initiative to to use money to
um you know pay for things to try and
prevent someone from becoming homeless
or from losing
um or enable them to gain accommodation
so
a huge amount of success has been done
in in all areas of the
of the housing strategy really
homelessness is just one element of it
but
i don't want people to think it's purely
as a result of the pandemic we're seeing
some success because actually the team
do achieve a huge amount of work and
incredibly dedicated to what they do
thank you very much that was a good
reminder of the good work that had been
being done in previous
months and years thank you uh councillor
keith scarf please
thank you chair actually gavin and
heather have just answered the question
regarding supported housing and
the moves on that so i i have no further
questions
thank you um councillor adrian osborne
thank you uh mr chairman first of all
could i
just say that i have the highest praise
for for heather
and gavin and the team i think they've
done excellently
uh with with everything uh regardless
homeless and
etc just a a couple of uh points i just
wanted to make and and
i've clarified first of all with
homeless uh
situations have you found that um
it is difficult to interact with with
some of the uh
rough sleepers in terms of
them not coming to you or you unable to
actually speak to them in terms of
what is required and the other uh aspect
is
have you found that that we have had a
lot of
in import from other count other areas
uh essex ie and um
other areas uh around that that have
come into here looking for actual
accommodation and
obviously uh housing thank you
thank you councillor osborne and in the
first point in regards to the engagement
with rough sleepers
and i think it's fair to say that some
engage better than others and actually
a lot of these individuals may you know
will have reasons why they're on the
street so there may be
you know significant trauma they may
have faced in the past
and they may be mistrusting of of people
in authority and they may be unwilling
to talk to us to start with
but it's not a case that we go out and
try and talk to them once and if they
don't want to talk to us we just ignore
them
we will continually try and engage with
them we'll look at ways
that we can try and get them to start
trusting us and it it it can be quite a
long process to
to build up that conversation and get to
a point where they start to want to
really work with us
and that's a real benefit we've seen
from the funding we got this year to
have our own dedicated
rough sleeper outreach worker who has
the time to be able to keep going out
and trying to engage with these
individuals
building that rapport building that
trust and trying to get a good
resolution for them and get them off the
streets
in regards to other areas we're not
seeing um an increasing
rough sleepers that are coming from
other areas they are generally from our
own areas
we do at times sometimes see people come
into the district that maybe
previously were you know just living
over the border and
we sometimes find that with baber you
know that we do border ipswich
but actually um you know at the moment
we're not seeing a significant rise in
that it is generally people from within
our districts that are
actually out on the streets at the
moment
thank you very much councillor jane
gould please
thank you mr chair yes um i've got a
question around
the impact of covid on evictions
um and for private tenancies
and private landlords and there's been
something that national government has
said hasn't the sort of the three-month
um sort of embargo on this and this talk
at national government level about
extending that to six months but and
there is the potential
um that when this is lifted and when
private landlords can actually evict
their tenants
there could be a whole influx of
families
um coming into to your attention ready
to our attention
um and it could well be also that that
will provide
private rental houses that they have
been evicted from for other people
um so my question really is
and i think i probably know the answer
um from what i've heard
do we feel that our current strategies
are going to be robust enough to cope
with
what could be quite a turbulent period
if this does all happen
um and is it advantageous perhaps to
um to pick up some of the tab for these
families who
may have lost their their jobs due to
covid to keep them in the private
rentals that they are
but i think i did pick up there's a fund
for that isn't that and thank you
heather you've kept my attention from
slide one to the end
of those who know me as i'm further up
the adhd spectrum than some some will
know that that is good
going thank you thank you councillor
gold
so in regard to the impact on evictions
unless anything's changed
since friday which hopefully well it may
well have done but
um as far as i'm aware the imp the end
um eviction ban actually ended yesterday
um it was due to end on the 23rd of
august and it literally like the 11th
hour it got an extension i'm not aware
there's been any extensions so as
from today evictions can now take place
again
however it's um it's extremely
complicated there's many many different
amendments that have been made to
various different sort of legislations
that we have to abide by
and people do have like longer notice
periods and things now
but as a team we've done a huge amount
of work to prepare for this so
when the um when the lockdown first was
first announced we got all of our
housing solutions officers to review
every single case that they were working
on everybody was contacted to understand
um for single people that might have
been so for surfing whether or not they
could remain
for those living in private rent who
were under a notice um
before the eviction ban came in we were
ringing those landlords we were
talking to them we were actually
agreeing with them to hold off any
eviction
until such time as the lockdown ended at
a later date the eviction ban then came
in which kind of did that for us anyway
but we were already ahead of the game
we'd already done that
we've actually reviewed all of those
cases so we know exactly
who we've got that's likely to become
homeless at some point in the future
where they need to live what family size
they are for some of those individuals
where we knew the eviction was
um unpreventable and we knew that
actually it you know it was just a case
of waiting for that day to come
we actually have been able to house some
of those people already ahead of that
eviction actually taking place
we've really tried to be proactive in
that approach we have got a list of
people that we still think homelessness
is inevitable
and we haven't got a date for yet and
we're still actively engaging with those
individuals
when we first got the ban and we worked
out how many kind of eviction cases we
deal with year on year
we are expecting to see a massive influx
and a real pressure and we started
looking at how we might prepare for that
but actually because of the successful
work the team have had to date
and because of the work we're still able
to do around prevention
actually we don't think the numbers are
going to be quite as sort of
catastrophic for us as we we initially
kind of were predicting
however there may well be lots of people
that we're not aware of yet that aren't
on our radar
but we have been having conversations
with private landlords and actually
asking them to
to tell people about us tell them about
the service we can provide
because of data protection they can't
share those tenants details with us who
might be having affordability issues
but what we're saying to them is tell
them we're here tell them that we offer
tenancy support
we can offer financial inclusion advice
we can help with accessing benefits
we can also look at alternative housing
options that might be more affordable
don't leave it until such time as they
get a notice or their imminent risk of
losing their home because
the earlier we you know the team can
work with somebody the better
and and the more likely we are to be
successful in our outcome
we do have lots of other string you know
sort of tools available to us we've got
the guaranteed rent scheme we've got the
rent deposit scheme and we have got the
homes prevention fund as well
we've also got a fantastic team of
tenancy support officers who focus on
financial inclusion and income
maximization
and if people come forward to us with
rent areas
they will look at their income they will
look at whether there's any benefits
they should be applying for they're not
in receipt of
they will look to try and apply for any
discretionary loans discretion with
grants
and discretionary benefits they might be
entitled to to help make
their accommodation more affordable so
um
the team are doing a huge amount of work
in regards to that
also in regards to social housing in our
own stock
we actually made a commitment very early
on in the pandemic that we wouldn't take
any
action to evict anybody as a direct
result of the pandemic so we've done
that even before the government
announcement
so as an organization um you know we
made that commitment as well
thank you very much can i just start a
supplemental which is that there is also
an impact on
private landlords if they're just a
small landlord with maybe just one other
property to rent
um and they lose the money from that it
has the impact that the landlord is
financially impacted as well and they
have trouble
himself paying his bills because he was
dependent on that
income stream from the one property that
that he rented
yeah absolutely and we're very acutely
aware of that and we we do
you know believe nationally there's
likely to be a number of landlords that
may well withdraw from the market as a
result of
of you know the eviction ban and the
restrictions around what they can do
um but we would encourage anyone that's
having affordability issues to come
forward because we you know if we can
get that rent back up and running in
payment
again um you know officer will make that
easier for that landlord
yeah thank you thank you thank you very
much i've i've just got
councillor paul epping young left and
then i will come to people
as they raise their hands but council
rapping young please
thank you mr chairman um i too would
like to
echo the commendation uh of
the work that's being done by heather uh
gavin and their team
uh if it's extremely good work and
very valuable work um and uh
councilman muller already picked up my
issue with uh homelessness in stone
markets i look forward to receiving
the email from heather on that point but
i have one just
minor point to note in heather's
presentation which was
very good indeed but that with regard to
the needham market hq
uh site um in fact we're going to have
93
homes there of which 10 will be
affordable due to
some redesign of the site that we
undertook
recently thank you thank you
right i've now got councillor carter
listed
thank you sorry having a bit of a
troublesome keyboard
um i did wonder would it be possible for
if you have records of problem
areas of rough sleeping in councillor's
wards would it be possible to notify the
count the councillors involved of said
number of
rough sleepers that you are engaging
with
just so we are aware in case there's
anything that we can uh
possibly do to outreach as well so we
can be uh
even if we aren't able to house these
people if we were
able to talk to somebody this would be a
point of contact with the council that
they may trust
i'm not not sure through the information
you were allowed to do that but i did
wonder if it might be
of any benefit yeah yeah
certainly i'll look into that the other
thing is that if you do ever notice any
of us sleepers
you know it may be that we've not been
notified of them because we you know we
cover a huge geographical
area um there is you know we do
encourage anyone that notices a sleeper
to refer them through street link which
is a
national um website where you just put
the report in it comes
straight through to the team and we try
and get somebody out in 24 hours to
engage with them so
i'd urge any any members if you do see
any rust sleepers anywhere and we
haven't been in contact with you and
just
you know and made you aware or you think
we might not know that they're there
please do let us know so we can get the
team out as soon as possible please
thank you thank you heather i've got
councillor grandin after
after councillor grandma's question i'd
like to move on to debate if so
if we can because we're getting very
close to debating rather than questions
so councillor grandin and then we'll
move on to debate
thank you um i've got a question about
allocation um you
mentioned in your presentation about
um reviewing um allocation
um how you're doing it and the needs of
older and vulnerable people um
i've had i think as you're probably
aware
at least three experiences
um regarding allocation
um policy um
a couple of them are maybe due to the
um de-sheltering
of um our houses
um a while ago
that have resulted in um the existing
tenants um so someone has been allocated
um one of our properties but the
existing talents
who may have been in um sheltered
accommodation before that has now been
de-sheltered
be not being able to live a
quiet um
normal life um
due to the person that's been allocated
to that property who doesn't fit in
with the lifestyle of
all the existing tenants now it's all
very well giving someone a home for life
but if this home that they're being
given or or if this person doesn't fit
in with all the
all our other neighboring tenants or
even people in the commercial
in the private sector is this a good
policy
for everyone else i'm i'm a bit
concerned about
how you know what i is this something
that could be reviewed
um as well because i don't know if
our allocation policy is working
i think there's two points here so in
regards to the view of choice-based
lettings we've made a commitment and
we did start it um just before the
lockdown was announced actually and we
had meetings with councillor
jan osborne and councillor julie flatman
and in their roles as cabinet holders
for housing
and the proposal initially was that we
would hold some workshops with with
councillors during the summer period
where we try and understand what council
is concerned where about the allocations
policy
and things they might want to see in it
in the future or in how the system is
operated
obviously because of the restrictions
affecting us at the moment that wasn't
possible
we did try and start the process by
doing a councillor survey
which we had quite a good response rate
too
and we've been reviewing the results of
that with a view to hopefully
holding some member workshops later this
year um albeit probably virtually
through
microsoft teams and in regards to local
lettings policy so we do have a number
of local lettings policies across the
districts and these sit
underneath the allocations policy not
set out in the allocations policy
the policy refers to the fact we can
hold our own local lettings policies and
we then
create our own so we do have one around
the sheltered
stock um and that individuals housed
into properties there
need to be um of what we call a quiet
and settled lifestyle
as far as we're aware and obviously we
you know we don't know every person
um you know inside out we don't know
whether there may be issues we do our
best to assess as much as we possibly
can
and generally speaking we very very
rarely ever come across
an issue and if we do then it's dealt
with by the housing management team
and they look at actually whether or not
that individual is actually doing
something that actually breaches their
tenancy
sometimes and i can think of a case
recently where it's just a case of not
necessarily understanding what their
tendency conditions were
um they were the housing officer went
out and visited them and spoke to them
and we've had no further complaints
since if it's an issue around actually
they're not adhering to their tenancy
conditions and actually warnings can be
put in place and we can actually
um and deal with that through the
through the tenancy management process
but it's very very rare that occurrences
like this come up
i mean the other thing to bear in mind
one of the challenges around a local
lettings policy for example for d
sheltered is you can set a policy up to
say five years with a view that you know
it's an older population living there
previously in a sheltered scheme
the longer it goes on for actually those
people may have moved on
and the next people that have moved in
they may well be older and you get to a
position if not where actually you could
have large amounts of stock across the
districts
that are actually being designated only
for the older population and you could
run the risk there's less accommodation
available for you know the younger
population but we have actually um
as part of our service plan we're
devising at the moment for next year
one of the actions we've we've put in
there is to actually review all of the
local letting
policies across both of the districts to
actually look at what we've got how long
they've been in place and which ones
may need to be reviewed or updated
thank you very much uh that that was an
interesting point because i have
i've heard of places where younger
people have moved
into former sheltered housing
and the young family that moves in is so
grateful to have
an older person living next door and
vice versa so i think
it depends it depends on the tenant more
rather than the
the age of the tenant so it has worked
very well in some places i'm aware
right so we're on to debate
and can i first go to councillor david
muller
thank you chair um basically i've got
nothing further to add really i said
it's an excellent report
uh big thank you to heather and her team
um
um basically that's it i've got nothing
else else to say actually
chair thank you thank you council
alistair mccraw
oh sorry about that chair uh
the fingertip
you are you are muted at present
counselor
my mccraw finger passed and moved on and
they
double double must have double clicked
i've been looking at the risk management
on this report and i think these are the
key risks
the major changes in the state of the
market
there are identified the lack of
resources to implement the strategy
lack of outside support and unforeseen
pressures and we're going through one of
the
classic unforeseen circumstances that we
could possibly
manage i think we've got to make a
recommendation within this
report and our response to it that we
recognize that how important
housing is it's one of our key functions
and a housing strategy
might not be statutory required but it
is an
absolutely essential point that every
council should be able to address
and i think we should be looking to
reinforce
the importance of this to the council
to uh to other members
and to the cabinet i'm sure they
recognize it already but i don't think
it can hurt to restate this
that this is a primary function i think
that's something
that could be included within the
recommendations in some form or other
it's an it's a really good it's a high
level strategy
it's not something to um you can pick
the bones out of individual parts of it
but it does really
come together in the course of the last
two or three years well two years
particularly
heather's been working really hard on
this i know and we've seen
different aspects of it we've examined
different aspects of it in the past
and i think we should be doing
everything we can
to continue that good work and provide
the political support
for the actual practical work so i'd
like to see that reflected
in our recommendations i will be
supporting something along those lines
thank you very much that's brilliant
thank you
uh councillor adrian osborne please
yeah thank you thank you mr sorry about
that i got a bit mislaid there
um yeah i i i'm i'm happy with
the way things are that that just a
a remember a question that comes up and
that is that
um there are there are uh properties
that are vacant
and uh obviously the criteria for
the way that that is then used uh goes
into a lot of
uh a lot of legal depth i believe so
obviously we've got a situation here
where
uh a lot of residents uh
are un uh unaware of the way that the
uh the if you like the empty properties
that are
around uh can't be dealt with uh as they
wish
could uh heather just sort of respond on
that
certainly councillor osborne and in
regards to empty homes it's a very
complex process and
it would be wonderful if we could wave a
magic wand and bring them back into use
quickly
the reality is that it actually it is a
long it is a long process and it
if the if the owner is not willing to to
work with us
you know to go through the legal process
can take a considerable time
easily upwards of a couple of years but
um as i mentioned in my presentation we
have done a review of the private sector
housing service
and since i took it over in september
last year and i've got a plan for what i
would like the service to look like in
the future
um so we are hoping to be able to
develop the service and actually deliver
it in a slightly different way and i'd
like to see
um you know us be able to do more work
around the empty homes work and
and other areas as well including energy
efficiency and things in
the private rented sector thank you very
much
um right councillor terence carter
please
uh thank you i'd like to second what
alex
councillor mckenna mccoy said before as
well regarding
how the importance of this report can be
2d to make it
a double underlined are safe for the
rest of the accounts
um i did that just a very
strange query regarding um it's not just
empty
homes but there's been reports in the
past regarding
empty commercial properties where uh
rough sleepers have taken over these
properties and turned them into
makeshift um
uh makeshift uh
uh homeless shelters uh there was one
that was
actually rewarded to be tenancy of a
property i believe
in a london borough a year before last
where the
uh the squatters actually have been
given
the prohibition and they were doing a
study into how
the effects of this actually how it
reduced numbers of rough sleepers
uh has anything been looked into regards
that were
using a vacant commercial properties
for makeshift shelters uh in this area
yeah thank you gavin fisk
uh thank you chair um i mean just on
councillor carter's point uh we don't
have
uh rough sleepers in commercial units if
we were to find
uh russ leapers in vacant commercial
units would obviously
work with those and uh the necessary
authorities to ensure
um that they were moved on uh obviously
there's there's risks of of individuals
living in
in in units if if people are not aware
um i just really wanted to take the
opportunity
and forgive me for for digressing but i
just want to take the opportunity to
uh talk to members about the fact that
um i think what you need to be mindful
of this morning and it's clear that the
discussion has
got a lot of breadth um because housing
is so broad
that this is a housing strategy it's a
five-year strategy
it's there to support and underpin the
policies and the strategies
that um actually uh support your
residents your constituents
in the borough in the districts of baby
mid suffolk
um in relation to to all things housing
so
i think what we've seen this morning is
we've touched on some of the detail in
terms of
a rough sleeper sleeping on the street
or an empty property that someone might
walk past
i think the key for me as members is
that you need the reassurance
and peace of mind that the councils have
the strategies in place to combat and
tackle
those specific issues and hopefully that
has been demonstrated by this
conversation and debate
as as well as the the actions that are
being delivered
um but i guess you need the reassurance
that going forward
uh based on some of those things based
on performance data
and based on the linkages to other
district strategies such as the
environment
the community strategies that actually
these strategies are working
in tandem together to deliver uh results
for for our residents
uh and not in isolation
thank you gary yeah you said something
that i was similar to what i was going
to say a bit later on when when i had
had my two pennies um if we can
for the time being continue around the
list if i can
return to it um councillor jane gould
please
thank you i've got nothing else to add
thank you very much
um councillor paul epping young
uh thank you mr chairman i do have
nothing further to add
thank you councillor keith scarf
thank you mr chairman yeah i think um
work on both the strategies progress
has definitely been evidenced today
obviously we've concentrated i think
largely on the uh homeless situation but
i didn't want us to overlook the fact
that um
work on the overall housing strategy has
has progressed
i think one of the issues for us will be
um
if we're unsuccessful in our bid for a
supported housing scheme
how we progress that um if if we are
unsuccessful and let us hope that we
will be successful um
heather and her team um because there's
a clear
i think need for supported housing um
within within the area so um just wanted
to make that as a comment really
thank you thank you thank you very much
councillor catherine grandin
i have nothing to add thank you chairman
thank you i think everybody's had one
one go i was just going to mention two
or three other things which um
i picked up from this um and
i don't know how the strategy can react
to this but
it seems that two things seem to be
happening
um as far as housing in some of the
rural areas are concerned
one is that people are moving into our
districts from more expensive areas
and and by doing that that may
accelerate um people working from home
quite a number of people around where i
live um
have previously lived sorry lived and
worked
lived close to london worked in london
and
now they are quite content working from
home and i've spoken to them and i said
well
you know now that the restrictions are
being lifted a bit are you going back oh
well i will never go back to the office
so i wonder if this
this sort of increase in people moving
from expensive areas to cheaper areas
is going to uh be good or bad for the
local economy
and good or bad for the communities um
when we went to lockdown we we had a lot
of office
offers of help from the community but
this may well drop away as people
return to work in places like essex and
cambridge from
from the stone market area um so
should we be looking to um provide
homes and jobs for people who work and
live in
in in mid-suffolk and in uh baby
should we be providing homes that are
of the home office type should we be
looking
at um more of those
um and i think you know we
we do we do need to make sure that
the homes that we provide and the people
who move
obviously people move into them we need
to make sure that they
are contributing to a vibrant
uh community it's a responsibility that
we need to share across both districts
um
um and one other thing
there was mention of neighborhood plans
um
i'll forget which aim it was but one of
the one of the aims
um was to do with um and vision five
also i think is to do with
um neighborhood plans and local planning
um it seems that the nppf
and more recently the um the the the
the white paper um
is gonna make it more difficult to get
people
to produce the neighborhood plans i know
locally around the stone market areas in
some of the villages
it's people are feeling that
their neighborhood plans have been
ignored and
in terms of updating them when the joint
local plan comes in
um i think it's going to be difficult to
persuade
communities to update their neighborhood
plans
but i think we we need if we're going to
have
any form of community planning of of
housing development
we've got to do something to encourage
involvement and realistic involvement
and that
historically that's been through
neighborhood plans i don't think there's
a question there it's just just my sort
of feelings
um looking through looking through the
report
um so uh i think everyone has had
a say um councillor mccrory i think you
were
you were giving some thoughts to a a
recommendation
or a proposal i i don't know if you've
got anything else you'd like to say
whether you would want to
be happy to propose um
obviously 3.1 um as stated
and and for 3.2 that
the committee recognize
that housing and our strategy for it
is one of our primary functions and that
we urge the cabinet
to continue uh in the support to
continue in the
strand of looking for support from
central government
um in whatever
new reality emerges it's difficult to
get the wording right i appreciate
uh what i'm trying to suggest is that
we not only endorsed this report but we
stressed as councillor carter said we
double underline
the importance of this that this is a
key function
um and we should recognize that and we
should state it
um because it is as overall it's an
overall strategy
uh we're not just looking at some of the
particular examples we've taken
it's about how do we get over the fact
that uh the multiplier is 10 or 11 in
baber and mid suffolk
um we can't control who moves into the
district we want people to move into the
district but they have to be places for
them to go to
and they have to be fit and proper
places for them to to live in
and in whatever form of life that they
choose to have or we
or or or works out in the future so
the key thing is just to stress the
importance of this and to
keep insisting that this become one of
the primary focuses
of any good council we're building more
council houses
we're building we're looking for um more
partnerships there's a one in coming up
in my own ward the work is just about to
start
once they can get the planning
conditions agreed uh
all these things have taken time but
they are coming to some fruition in the
course of the last few years
and uh that's something that was not the
case uh 20 years ago or even 30 years
ago
so we are moving in the right direction
but that means that the pressure must be
kept up so
i think just some way of saying we
recognize the importance of the housing
strategy that is one of our primary
functions
and stress that it should have received
as much political support across all
groups
and the cabinet in the future
so i don't know if henriette can can
put that into the most suitable language
normally i've
i have an idea but i don't have in this
one because it's such a
it's such a vague sort of um idealistic
approach but i just think this double
underlining is
absolutely crucial we must do it can i
can i just
i've made some notes and i just wonder
if this this might
more or less fit the bill and then
anyone else um
chip in that members thank officers for
their report presentation and the work
they have been carrying out
especially at the commencement of the
kovid restrictions
um and i was going to put something
about their their innovative approach in
there as well perhaps because they're
and they've been very successful in
their in in bids and
and the work that they've done and to
recognize the importance of these
strategies
and stress that housing continues to be
recognized
by cabinet and council as a key priority
yeah or i was going to say or one of our
primary uh or one of our primary
functions as a counselor say primary
function yeah
i think that's a fair description of a
local authority at a district level
that this is one of the primary
functions of
any decent local authority
you don't have to include the word
decent any local authority
so yeah so
um i mean um councillor mccrory
interrupt if you feel that we need to
change the word slightly
um members thank officers for their
report presentation and for the work
they've been carried out
carrying out especially at the
commencement of covid restrictions
and for their innovative approach to
delivering housing
not delivering housing delivering
to the their innovative approach
delivering a housing strategy
or delivering these strategies
since those homes housing homelessness
reduction and rough sleeping
these strategies and recognize the
important as a
three point to recognize the importance
of these strategies
and stress that housing continues should
continue to be recognized by cabinet and
council
as a primary function yes
so housing and these strategies
okay because they address that primary
function
well recognize the importance of these
strategies and stress that
housing continues to be recognized by
cabinet council
as a primary function okay i'd like to
suggest that as 3.2
uh with the 3.1 as suggested in the
paper
and i would so propose i i've just uh
i suggested rather than we just note the
contents of the report that we thank
them
oh yes um
uh and we thank them for the
presentation rather than note the verbal
contributions
um henry if you've got that i can
after the meeting i can send that to you
if that will help
or we can just compare notes so
councilman mcgraw
are you proposing that i am so proposing
thank you do i have a seconder
councillor carter you have your hand up
uh yes i'm happy to second that i was
trying to run it through grammarly and
crash
the computer so i i've seen most of it
is written right uh
but yes uh happy second that thank you
very much
so we have a proposal we have a seconder
so
could i ask the governance officer to
carry out a roll call vote please
certainly chair counselor carter
four especially if we can get this
keyboard to work yes
four councillor grandin four
council gould four councillor
young four councillor mccrore
councillor muller four councillor
osborne
thank you very much now i'm i would
suggest
that we have a comfort break now for a
few minutes
um but could i ask
the officers is it is it better to
resolve to exclude the public from the
next item before or after we have the
break
or does it make no difference uh
let me just think um i think i would
like to do a roll call maybe come back
from the break
chair and then go into um private
session if that's okay
okay that's fine is that i think that's
probably
i'm just thinking the practicality of
that actually um
would we agree with that is that the
best way of doing it i think yes we'll
do a roll call
back and then we go into private session
right okay
if i may just confirm it it's emily
emily your motion officer
um as henriette said i think the best
process would be to come back from the
break
check that everybody's back in the
meeting and then take the uh vote to
move into closed session
thank you thanks so can we all be back
at 11 45
then please that okay
yeah thank you
welcome back to the meeting we are now
moving on to
item 12 which is the resolution to
exclude the public which is which
can i do it do a roll call first to make
sure everybody's actually reading i do
apologize
knows me sorry yes i'm doing a room call
now thank you
um councillor gould yes i'm here
council grandin
council grand and you're mute i'm here
thank you councilman crawl present
counselor osborne present council carter
present uh councillor kenyon
and yes we're moving on to item 12 which
is the
resolution to exclude the public which
terms include
the press we will now go into closed
session to discuss the next item on the
agenda
to consider whether pursuant to part one
of schedule 12a of the local government
act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the per
business specified below on the grounds
that
if the public were present during this
item
it is likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against the item the author
of the report
proposed to be considered in part two of
the agenda
is satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information
do i have a proposal please
i'll propose that chair thank you
councillor mccraw
and the seconder i'll propose that thank
you councillor
adrian osborne thank you so
the government the government's officer
will now can
conduct a roll call vote okay
councillor councillor carter
councillor grandin
cancer grandina and mute four
council gold four council epcon young
four councilman crawl
council muller for
so the government's offices now will
confirm when the live stream
has ended
and we're back on youtube chair thank
you very much
we are now going to consider together
items 7
10 and 11 so that's the key decisions
list the baba and the mid suffolk
work plans
can you note that the next meeting of
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee sorry can we
can you note that the overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
in january will be on the 18th of
january not on the 14th as stated in the
work plans
does anybody have any comments on the
forthcomings forthcoming decisions list
first please did anyone see anything in
the decisions lists
that would require us to add anything to
the work plans
no
so uh if we look now at the
the two work plans there's a lot of
commonality
between the two because many of the
meetings are joint meetings
but um does anyone from baber have any
comment on the labor work plan
please
no does anyone from mid-suffolk have any
comment on the mid-suffolk work plan
sorry councilman i wasn't quick enough
on the trigger there
okay i do apologize
i think the wordpress 134 isn't it 133
134
yeah got it 133. it's just to note that
uh
by chairs agreements and just to make
sure all members are aware of the fact
that we've cancelled the meeting for the
19th of october
um because uh we've been rather busy
recently
and some reports wouldn't be ready in
time and so
uh everybody gets a slight break uh in
the october but then considering we've
been meeting about twice a month it
seems the last three months i don't
think
there's any harm in that thank you
councilman mccork can i just add the the
the um
february march and may meetings are
likely to be joint meetings
it's it's noted thus on the mid-suffolk
work plan but it needs to be noted
similarly on the baby work plan
chair i do apologize it's because the
the work plans has actually been updated
since then but uh this went to
uh publication before we we just before
the meeting so it should all be okay
on the current world plans but i'll make
sure members see those thank you very
much
so they are for noting i don't think we
have to
we don't we don't have to vote do we so
right may i just interrupt briefly chair
yes these will be the work plans that
are uh presented
to the uh annual councils later this
month are they not
yes the ones that we have attached to
this agenda i'm afraid are
so um i will possibly table a new work
plan for you would you um
appreciate that i think i think it's
best since we're reporting it
to cabinet um i meant to to count to
council
and um i can't remember which one will
cancel obviously
for babies tomorrow yes um but
uh that's really just for noting and so
minor changes are always possible
yes um would you
ask me to table a new updated voice plan
i don't think it's necessary i think we
can
because because it's a red fact that
sometimes small
minor changes are made okay that's fine
thank you jim
okay thank you um so we've noted the
labour work plan we note the
mid-suffolk work plan so this concludes
the meeting
the next meeting will be a joint meeting
on monday the 23rd of november
at 9 15 for a 9 30 start
thank you very much uh for attending
thank you very much for the offices
for all that they have done in the
background and the advice that they have
given
so that that finishes the meeting
thank you
you